i'm assuming that everybody here is
coming from part one we were talking
about hamming codes
a way to create a block of data where
most of the bits carry a meaningful
message
while a few others act as a kind of
redundancy in such a way that if
any bit gets flipped either a message
bit or redundancy bit anything in this
block
a receiver is going to be able to
identify that there was an error
and how to fix it the basic idea
presented there was how to use multiple
parity checks to binary search your way
down to the error
now in that video the goal was to make
hamming codes feel as
hands-on and rediscoverable as possible
but
as you start to think about actually
implementing this either in software or
hardware
that framing may actually undersell how
elegant these codes really are you might
think that you need to write an
algorithm that keeps track of all the
possible error locations and
cuts that group in half with each check
but it's actually way
way simpler than that if you read out
the answers to the four parity checks we
did in the last video
all is ones and zeros instead of yeses
and no's it literally spells out the
position of the error in binary
for example the number seven in binary
looks like zero one one one
essentially saying that it's four plus
two plus one
and notice where the position seven sits
it does affect the first of our parity
groups
and the second and the third
but not the last so reading the results
of those four checks from bottom to top
indeed does spell out the position of
the error there's nothing special about
the example 7 this works in general
and this makes the logic for
implementing the whole scheme and
hardware
shockingly simple now if you want to see
why this magic happens take these 16
index labels for our positions but
instead of writing them in base 10
let's write them all in binary running
from 0 0 0
0 up to 1 1 1 1. as we put these binary
labels
back into their boxes let me emphasize
that they are distinct
from the data that's actually being sent
they're nothing more than a conceptual
label
to help you and me understand where the
four parity groups came from
the elegance of having everything that
we're looking at be described in binary
is maybe undercut by the confusion of
having everything we're looking at being
described in binary
it's worth it though focus your
attention just on that last bit of all
of these labels
and then highlight the positions where
that final bit is a one
what we get is the first of our four
parity groups
which means that you can interpret that
first check as asking
hey if there's an error is the final bit
in the position of that error
a one similarly if you focus
on the second to last bit and highlight
all the positions where that's a one
you get the second parity group from our
scheme in other words
that second check is asking hey me again
if there's an error
is the second to last bit of that
position a one
and so on the third parity check covers
every position
whose third to last bit is turned on
and the last one covers the last eight
positions
those ones whose highest order bit is a
one
everything we did earlier is the same as
answering these four
questions which in turn is the same as
spelling out a position in binary
i hope this makes two things clearer the
first is how to systematically
generalize to block sizes that are
bigger powers of 2
if it takes more bits to describe each
position like
6 bits to describe 64 spots then each of
those bits
gives you one of the parity groups that
we need to check
those of you who watch the chessboard
puzzle i did with matt parker might find
all this
exceedingly familiar it's the same core
logic but solving a different problem
and applied to a 64 squared chessboard
the second thing i hope this makes clear
is why our parity bits are sitting in
the positions that are powers of two
for example one two four and eight these
are the positions whose binary
representation has just a single bit
turned on
what that means is each of those parity
bits sits inside one
and only one of the four parity groups
you can also see this in larger examples
where no matter how big you get
each parity bit conveniently touches
only one of the groups
once you understand that these parody
checks that we've focused so much of our
time on
are nothing more than a clever way to
spell out the position of an error in
binary
well then we can draw a connection with
a different way to think about hamming
codes
one that is arguably a lot simpler and
more elegant and which can basically be
written down with a single line of code
it's based on the xor function
xor for those of you who don't know
stands for exclusive or
when you take the xor of two bits it's
going to return a 1
if either one of those bits is turned on
but not if both are turned on or if both
are turned off
phrase differently it's the parity of
these two bits
as a math person i prefer to think about
it as addition mod 2.
we also commonly talk about the xor of
two different bit strings
which basically does this component by
component it's like addition but where
you never carry
again the more mathematically inclined
might prefer to think of this as
adding two vectors and reducing mod 2.
if you open up some python right now and
you apply the carrot operation between
two integers
this is what it's doing but to the bit
representations of those numbers under
the hood
[Music]
the key point for you and me is that
taking the xor of many different bit
strings
is effectively a way to compute the
parodies of a bunch of separate groups
like so with the columns all in one fell
swoop
[Music]
this gives us a rather snazzy way to
think about the multiple parity checks
from our hamming code algorithm
as all being packaged together into one
single operation
though at first glance it does look very
different
specifically write down the 16 positions
in binary like we had before
and now highlight only the positions
where the message bit
is turned on to a one and then collect
these positions
into one big column and take the xor
you can probably guess that the four
bits sitting at the bottom as a result
are the same as the four parity checks
that we've come to know and love
but take a moment to actually think
about why exactly
this last column for example is counting
all of the positions whose last bit is a
one
but we're already limited only to the
highlighted positions
so it's effectively counting how many
highlighted positions
came from the first parity group does
that make sense
likewise the next column counts how many
positions are in the second parity group
the positions whose second to last bit
is a one and which are also highlighted
and so on it's really just a small shift
in perspective
on the same thing that we've been doing
[Music]
and so you know where it goes from here
the sender is responsible for toggling
some of the special parity bits to make
sure that the sum works out to be
zero zero zero zero
now once we have it like this this gives
us a really nice way to think about
why these four resulting bits at the
bottom directly spell out the position
of an error
let's say some bit in this block gets
toggled from a 0 to a 1.
what that means is that the position of
that bit is now going to be included in
the total xor
which changes the sum from being 0 to
instead being this
newly included value the position of the
error
slightly less obviously the same is true
if there's an error that changes a one
to a zero
you see if you add a bit string together
twice
it's the same as not having it there at
all basically because in this world one
plus one equals zero
so adding a copy of this position to the
total sum
has the same effect as removing it and
that effect again
is that the total result at the bottom
here spells out the position of the
error
to illustrate how elegant this is let me
show that one line of python code i
referenced before
which will capture almost all of the
logic on the receiver's end
we'll start by creating a random array
of 16 ones and zeros to simulate the
data block
and i'll go ahead and give it the name
bits but of course in practice this
would be something that we're receiving
from a sender
and instead of being random it would be
carrying 11 data bits together with five
parity bits
if i call the function enumerate bits
what it does is pair together each of
those bits with a corresponding index
in this case running from 0 up to 15.
so if we then create a list that loops
over all of these pairs
pairs that look like i a bit and then we
pull out
just the i value just the index well
it's not that exciting we just get back
those indices 0
through 15. but if we add on the
condition to only do this
if bit meaning if that bit is a 1 and
not a zero
well then it pulls out only the
positions where the corresponding bit is
turned on
in this case it looks like those
positions are 0 4
6 9 etc
remember what we want is to collect
together all of those positions
the positions of the bits that are
turned on and then xor them together
to do this in python let me first import
a couple helpful functions
that way we can call reduce on this list
and use the xor function to reduce it
this basically eats its way through the
list taking xors along the way
[Music]
if you prefer you can explicitly write
out that xor function without having to
import it from anywhere
so at the moment it looks like if we do
this on our random block of 16 bits
it returns 9 which has the binary
representation
1 0 0 1. we won't do it here but you
could write a function
where the sender uses that binary
representation
to set the four parity bits as needed
ultimately getting this block to a state
where running this line of code on the
full list of bits returns a zero
this would be considered a well-prepared
block
now what's cool is that if we toggle any
one of the bits in this list
simulating a random error from noise
then if you run the same line of code
what it does is it prints out that error
isn't that neat
you could get this block from out of the
blue run this single line
on it and what it'll do is automatically
spit out the position of an error
or a zero if there wasn't any
and there's nothing special about the
size 16 here the same line of code would
work if you had a list of
say 256 bits
[Music]
needless to say there is more code to
write here like doing the meta parity
check to detect two-bit errors
but the idea is that almost all of the
core logic from our scheme
comes down to a single xor reduction
now depending on your comfort with
binary and xors and software in general
you may either find this perspective a
little bit confusing
or so much more elegant and simple that
you're wondering why we didn't just
start with it from the get go
loosely speaking the multiple parity
check perspective is easier to think
about when implementing hamming codes in
hardware
very directly and the xor perspective is
easiest to think about
when doing it in software from kind of a
higher level
the first one is easiest to actually do
by hand and i think it does a better job
instilling the core intuition
underlying all of this which is that the
information required to locate a single
error
is related to the log of the size of the
block
or in other words it grows one bit at a
time as the block size doubles
the relevant fact here is that that
information directly corresponds to how
much redundancy we need
that's really what runs against most
people's knee-jerk reaction when they
first think about making a message
resilient to errors
where usually copying the whole message
is the first instinct that comes to mind
and then by the way there is this whole
other way that you sometimes see hamming
codes presented
where you multiply the message by one
big matrix it's kind of nice because it
relates it to the broader family of
linear codes but i think that gives
almost no intuition for where it comes
from
or how it scales
and speaking of scaling you might notice
that the efficiency of this scheme
only gets better as we increase the
block size
for example we saw that with 256 bits
you're using only three percent of that
space for redundancy
and it just keeps getting better from
there as the number of parity bits grows
one by one
the block size keeps doubling and if you
take that to an extreme
you can have a block with say a million
bits
where you would quite literally be
playing 20 questions with your parody
checks
and it uses only 21 parity bits
and if you step back to think about
looking at a million bits and locating a
single error
that genuinely feels crazy the problem
of course is that with a larger block
the probability of seeing more than one
or two bit errors
goes up and hamming codes do not handle
anything beyond that
so in practice what you'd want is to
find the right size so that the
probability of too many bit flips
isn't too high
also in practice errors tend to come in
little bursts
which would totally ruin a single block
so one common tactic to help spread out
a burst of errors across many different
blocks
is to interlace those blocks like this
before they're sent out or stored
then again a lot of this is rendered
completely moved by more modern codes
like the much more commonly used read
solomon algorithm which handles burst
errors particularly well
and it can be tuned to be resilient to a
larger number of errors per block
but that is a topic for another time
in his book the art of doing science and
engineering hamming is wonderfully
candid about just how meandering his
discovery of this code was
he first tried all sorts of different
schemes involving organizing the bits
into parts of a higher dimensional
lattice and strange things like this
the idea that it might be possible to
get parody checks to conspire in a way
that spells out the position of an error
only came to hamming when he stepped
back after a bunch of other analysis
and asked okay what is the most
efficient i could conceivably be about
this
he was also candid about how important
it was that parody checks were already
on his mind
which would have been way less common
back in the 1940s than it is today
there are like half a dozen times
throughout this book that he references
the louis pasteur quote
luck favors a prepared mind clever ideas
often look deceptively simple in
hindsight which makes them easy to
under-appreciate
right now my honest hope is that hamming
codes or at least the possibility of
such codes
feels almost obvious to you but you
shouldn't fool yourself into thinking
that they actually
are obvious because they definitely
aren't
part of the reason that clever ideas
look deceptively easy
is that we only ever see the final
result cleaning up what was messy
never mentioning all of the wrong turns
underselling just how vast the space of
explorable possibilities is at the start
of a problem-solving process
all of that but this is true in general
i think for some special inventions
there's a second deeper reason that we
under-appreciate them
thinking of information in terms of bits
had only really coalesced into a full
theory by 1948
with claude shannon seminal paper on
information theory
this was essentially concurrent with
when hamming developed his algorithm
this was the same foundational paper
that showed in a certain sense
that efficient error correction is
always possible no matter how high the
probability of bit flips
at least in theory shannon and hamming
by the way
shared an office in bell labs despite
working on very different things
which hardly seems coincidental here
fast forward several decades and these
days many of us are so immersed in
thinking about bits
and information that it's easy to
overlook just how distinct this way of
thinking was
ironically the ideas that most
profoundly shape the ways that a future
generation thinks
will end up looking to that future
generation
well simpler than they really are
[Music]
you